>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> For those of you who are
here because you've been moved
by Jonathan Safran
Foer, the novelist.
His first novel, Everything
is an Illuminated,
came out in 2002 when
he was just 25.
That was followed --
[ Applause ]
-- that was followed
three years later
by Extremely Loud
and Incredibly Close,
[ Applause ]
two remarkable works of
fiction before the age of 30.
Marie Arana summed
up his achievement
in the Washington Post this way:
"Rarely does a writer as young
as Jonathan Foer display
such virtuosity and wisdom.
His prose is clever,
challenging, willfully constructed
to make you read it again and again.
And reading it," she added,
"you feel altered, chastened,
seared in the fire
of something new."
Jonathan is a D.C. native,
educated at Georgetown Day
and then Princeton, where the author
Joyce Carol Oates took an interest
in his work.
That first novel, Everything
is Illuminated,
was completed at Princeton but
then languished in a drawer
for a couple years,
rejected by five agents.
When Jonathan finally pulled
it out and tried again,
the same manuscript thrilled
several publishers and went
on to earn ecstatic reviews.
Now the world knows when Jonathan
Safran Foer strings some words
together, you'll want to read them.
Please join me in welcoming
Jonathan Safran Foer.
[ Applause ]
>> Jonathan Safran Foer: Hello.
Hello. Wow.
So our time together
is very, very brief.
We only have about 25 minutes or
so, so I want to make good use of it
because I'm very excited to be here.
I did grow up in Washington,
D.C. I was born here.
I left only for my adult life, and,
then, only for reasons that are hard
to describe, but I'm
always happy to come back.
I was anticipating a
very hot and humid day
and was really disappointed
by what I got,
[ Laughter ]
which is only a hot day,
this is not a humid day.
I remember humidity,
and this is not it.
So I wrote two novels, and
then I wrote this very,
very different book.
And I think that when
people approach it --
and I've seen this happen
in bookstores before --
I've seen someone pull it off
the shelf, look at the title,
and put it back on the shelf;
or take it from the self
and read the description and
put it back on the shelf.
And, you know, that's
-- it's a shame not --
not only because I would like
for people to read my book,
but because it speaks to a
discomfort we have with this subject
and ideas that we bring to
any conversation about it,
which basically boiled down to
that this is divisive issue,
or that it's an issue that will
inevitably lead to an argument,
or to some people feeling
one thing strongly
and some people feeling something
quite different strongly,
and those differences not
-- not being reconcilable.
And what I found when I did
the research for this book
and when I wrote it and in the
year since it was published
and I've traveled across
the country --
not only to major cities on the
East Coast and on the West Coast,
but to areas all over the
country -- to farming communities,
to inner city public schools, to
quite a diverse group of readers --
I found that nobody disagrees.
If I were to pose the question, "Is
it right or wrong to eat animals,"
I think most people in this room,
if this room reflected America,
about 96 percent of the room would
say, "Yes, it's perfectly right."
But that's actually not the
important question to ask.
The important question, which I
focus this book on, is it right
or wrong to raise animals in the
ways that we're raising them?
To have a farm system
like the one that we do
where animals are treated, as a
rule, in ways that would be illegal
if they were cats or dogs?
Is it right or wrong to have a farm
system that's the number one cause
of global warming, and not
just by a little, but by a lot?
It's responsible for more greenhouse
gas emissions than everything else
in the world put together.
Is it right or wrong to have
a farm system that according
to the United Nations --
not according to the PETA
or the Humane Society,
but according to the
United Nations --
is one of the top two
or three causes
of every significant
environmental problem
on the planet locally and globally?
Is it right or wrong to have a farm
system that is making us less able
to use antibiotics when we fall
ill or when our children fall ill?
And the list goes on and on.
And I've found that when
I ask that question --
the relevant question --
people are in agreement.
It's very hard to find an
American who is indifferent
to the treatment of animals.
Ninety-six percent
of Americans think
that there should be laws
protecting animals from cruelty.
If you can think of
anything else that 96 percent
of Americans agree on,
I would love to hear it.
And whether or not you believe
in global warming, whether
or not you think our environment is
in any peril, you certainly believe
that the quality of the air that
we breathe matters, and the quality
of the water that we drink matters.
And so we're in this odd
position where we have a subject
which is clearly and definitively
our most important relationship
to the environment and our most
important to the animal world,
and yet we haven't found a
good way to talk about it
that reflects these very American
values, these very human concerns.
And so I tried with this book not
to simply present an argument,
not to present journalism,
not to present philosophy
but to present a story that would
hopefully engage people who care,
which is to say everybody, in
a way that allows them to care,
that doesn't make them fear
hypocrisy or fear of wagging finger,
but instead says, "Hey, there's this
enormous territory in front of us,
an enormous number of choices,
and we can make choices
that better reflect our values."
The choice is not between
vegetarianism and being a carnivore.
The choice might be between
eating meat 21 meals a week
and eating it 20 meals a week.
If all Americans reduced their meat
consumption by one meal a week,
it would be the --
environmentally the equivalent
of taking five million
cars off the road.
It's a very powerful statistic.
And when someone says to me, you
know, I'm compelled by this story
that you're telling but I can't,
myself, become a vegetarian,
I just love meat too much; or
it's too important to my family
or my culture or my religion,
I understand and respect
that person perfectly well.
It took me 20 years to
become a vegetarian.
But when someone says I can't
remove one serving of meat a week,
that starts to sound
pathological, just weird.
[ Laughter ]
So I think that's the place
to start, and that's the place
that my book starts, the idea that
we need to eat less of this stuff
because it's killing our planet,
it's doing horrific things
to animals, and it's also injuring
our own bodies in ways that we know
about and in many ways that
we don't yet know about.
We've really made science
experiments
out of ourselves and our kids.
And one only need read the New
York Times or Washington Post
or U.S. Today or whatever you
read, to find more and more reasons
to be concerned about this subject.
So what I thought I would do is read
the first, little tiny bit book,
a couple of pages, and then -- to
give you a sense of what I mean
when I say that it's a story --
and then we'll open this
up the remaining time
to what I wish we had much more
time for, which is conversation.
"When I was young, I would
often spend the weekend
at my grandmother's house.
On the way in, Friday night, she
would lift me from the ground in one
of her fire-smothering hugs.
And on the way out,
Sunday afternoon,
I was again taken into the air.
It wasn't until years later that
I realized she was weighing me.
[ Laughter ]
My grandmother survived
the war barefoot,
scavenging other people's
inedibles --
rotting potatoes, discarded
scraps of meat, skins and the bits
that clung to bones and pits --
and so she never cared if I
colored outside the lines,
as long as I cut coupons
along the dashes.
In hotel buffets, while the
rest of us erected Golden Calves
of breakfast, she would make
sandwich upon sandwich to swaddle
in napkins and stash
in her bag for lunch.
It was my grandmother who taught me
that one tea bag makes as many cups
of tea as you're serving [Laughter ]
-- you just had to be very, very
patient and not mind iced tea --
and that every part of
the apple is edible.
Money was not the point.
Many of those coupons I clipped were
for foods that she would never buy.
And health wasn't the point.
She would beg me to drink Coke.
My grandmother never set a place
for herself at family dinners.
Even when there was
nothing more to be done --
no soup bowls to be topped
off, no pots to be stirred,
or ovens checked -- she
stayed in the kitchen
like a vigilant guard,
or prisoner in a tower.
As far as I could tell,
the sustenance that she got
from the food she made
didn't require her to eat it.
In the forests of Europe,
she ate to stay alive
until the next opportunity
to eat to stay alive.
In America, 50 years later,
we ate what pleased us.
Our cupboards were filled
with food bought on whims --
overpriced foodie food,
food that we didn't need --
and when the expiration date
passed, we threw it away
without smelling it;
eating was carefree.
My grandmother made that
life possible for us,
but she was herself unable
to shake the desperation.
Food for her was not food.
It was terror, dignity, gratitude,
vengeance, joyfulness, humiliation,
religion, history,
and, of course, love,
as if the fruits she always
offered us were picked
from the destroyed
branches of our family tree.
About half an hour after my son was
born, I went into the waiting room
to tell the gathered
family the good news.
You said "he," so it's a boy.
What's his name?
What does he look like?
Tell us everything.
I answered their questions
as quickly as I could,
then went to a corner and
turned on my cell phone.
"Grandma," I said, "we have a baby."
Her only phone is in the kitchen.
She picked up after the first ring
which meant she'd been sitting
at the table waiting for the call.
It was just after midnight.
Had she be clipping coupons or
preparing her chicken and carrots
to freeze for someone else
to eat at some future meal?
I'd never once seen or heard
her cry, but tears pushed
through her voice as she asked,
"How much does it weigh?"
[ Laughter ]
A few days after we came home
from the hospital, I sent a letter
to a friend including
a photo of my son
and some first impressions
of fatherhood.
He responded simply,
"Everything is possible again."
It was the perfect thing to write
because that was exactly
how it felt.
We could retell our stories and make
them better, more representative
or aspirational, or we could
choose to tell different stories.
The world itself had
another chance."
And I'm going to finish the
reading part with a one-page story
that my grandmother
told me, and this --
I took dictation, these
are her words.
It's a shame that I'm not an
actor because if I were able
to capture her accent, I think
you would understand the story
that much better, but it doesn't
take a great leap of empathy.
So as I said, this is my
grandmother: "We weren't rich,
but we always had enough.
Thursdays we baked bread and rolls
and they lasted the whole week.
Friday we had pancakes.
On Shabbat we always had a
chicken and soup with noodles.
You would go to the butcher
and ask for a little more fat;
the fattiest piece
was the best piece.
It wasn't like now.
We didn't have refrigerators,
but we had milk and cheese.
We didn't have every kind of
vegetable, but we had enough.
The things that you have
here and take for granted.
But we were happy.
We didn't know any better, and we
took what we had for granted, too.
Then it all changed.
During the war, it was hell
on earth, and I had nothing.
I left my family, you know.
I was always running, day and night,
because the Germans were
always right behind me.
If you stopped, you died.
And there was never enough food.
I became sicker and sicker from not
eating, and I'm not just talking
about being skin and bones;
I had sores all over my body,
and it became difficult
even to move.
I wasn't too good to
eat from a garbage can.
I ate the parts that
others wouldn't eat.
I took whatever I could
find, and I ate things
that I wouldn't tell you about.
Even at the worst times,
there were good people, too.
Someone taught me to tie the ends
of my pants so I could fill the legs
with any potatoes I
was able to steal.
I walked miles and miles like
that because you never knew
when you would be lucky again.
The worst it got was near the end.
A lot of people died right
at the end, and I didn't know
if I could make it another day.
A farmer, a Russian, God bless
him, he saw my condition,
and he went into his house and came
out with a piece of meat for me.
"He saved your life," I said.
"Oh, I didn't eat it," she said.
"You didn't eat it?"
"It was pork.
I wouldn't eat pork."
[ Laughter ]
"Why," I asked, although,
of course, I knew why.
And she said, "What
do you mean why?"
And I said, "What?
Because it wasn't kosher?"
And she said, "Of course."
And I said, "But not
even to save your life?"
And she said, "If nothing
matters, there's nothing to save."
And that was really the
guiding principle of this book,
and I don't take the principle
to be one should be kosher.
I take the moral of this story to be
that we have to act on our values,
or at least there are certain
values that we have to act on
or we run the risk of -- of
losing something about ourselves
that is very much worth saving.
We run the risk of actually
not being ourselves anymore.
And so I spent about three years
learning about animal agriculture
in the United States, not
the philosophical question
of is it right or wrong to eat
meat; not, would it have been right
to eat meat 50 years ago, you know,
on the kinds of farms that were all
across America, but in 2010,
when 99 percent of the meat
that we eat comes from factory
farms, where animals are raised
in very great concentrations,
usually in very little space,
almost always in windowless sheds,
the environmental destruction
is built into the business plan
or it certainly seems to be,
it's the most environmental
destructive thing we do as humans,
and the animal cruelty is part
of the system, and that --
what I wanted to figure
out, is taking into account
that meat smells good
and tastes good --
I am that kind of vegetarian who
believes that meat tastes good
and smells good -- and
taking into account the fact
that meat can serve very
important cultural functions;
that it can bring us closer
to our families sometimes;
that it can make certain rituals
feel more whole; taking all of that
into account, what
is the value of meat
because it is not infinitely
valuable.
There are certain things that matter
more to me, and I think matter more
to all of us, and one of
those things is my ability
to tell my child stories
unflinchingly without glossing over,
without lying to him, especially
stories that are as primary
as where our food comes from,
stories that, knowingly or not,
we tell many times a day.
So I think that's an entrance
into what this book is.
And with the remaining time, I'd
be happy to try to answer any
of your questions about this or
about my other books or anything.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible ]
>> Jonathan Safran Foer: So she
was asking about my second book,
Extremely Loud and Incredibly
Close, and if it was going
to be turned into a movie.
And then she said some nice things
about the book which I can't repeat
because it'll sound like I'm
saying them about my own book.
[ Laughter ]
Somebody's working on it, and
theoretically it will be made
into a movie, but a lot of
things will theoretically happen
and never seem to happen.
I would say if we were
to compare the odds
of Iran getting a nuclear
bomb and my film being made --
my book being made into a film,
I would say they're about even.
[ Laughter ]
Which would you prefer?
Even if you hated my
book, it's still --
[ Laughter ]
>> Well, it's interesting
that you bring that book
up because it's obviously a very
difficult subject to write about,
especially for people who lived
in New York, experienced that,
and to write about it from
the perspective of a child --
as a child -- is, you know, a
brave choice, put it that way.
The narrative structure of the book
itself is interesting, though, too.
It in terms also in the way
that you incorporated, you know,
a flip book in it and
the other parts of it.
I guess as someone who is very
much growing up in the nuclear age,
how do you see the
book itself evolving?
You know, as you move
back to fiction,
do you expect to use more images
to create websites or videos,
to write something that you
know will be read in more
than just the printed page?
>> Jonathan Safran
Foer: Well, you know,
you said that it was an unusual
or risky choice to begin with,
to have a child as the
narrator of that book.
The book has September 11
as a backdrop, and this --
the young boy lost his
father on that day.
And Ron Charles, who I
think is probably not
in the audience right now but who's
a really wonderful book reviewer
for the Washington Post, wrote in
his review of my book that that day,
and by extension the book,
made children of all of us.
I happen to remember that
line, and I remember very,
very few lines of reviews.
And I think that he was
right, that there was a way
in which it reawakened a
kind of vulnerability in us,
also a sense of wonder or
astonishment, a sense of being small
in the face of things
that are very big, and,
of course, a child's anxiety.
It's interesting because the topic
of eating animals does
the exact reverse.
It makes adults of all of us in
the sense that we are very willing
to accept things that we know in our
hearts just aren't right in a way --
in ways that kids don't do.
If anyone's had the experience
of trying to explain to a kid
where meat comes from, you
know, it often involves a kind
of a pleasant version
of an unpleasant story,
and even then I think they're
good at sniffing out what's wrong
with the story that's
being told to them.
Now, as for the form
of the book, you know,
I don't think that books
need images at all.
My favorite books don't have images.
That book is filled with images and
it has a very maximal style in part
because I wanted the form
to reflect the content.
You know, Oscar, the hero,
has this very flamboyant,
maximal imagination.
He refers to his imagination
as being like beavers.
He says, "You know, beavers chop
down trees not only to build dams
but because if they weren't
constantly filing their teeth
down on trees, their
teeth would grow
into their own skulls
and they would die."
And he said, "My imagination
is like that.
Like it has to be active otherwise
I'd be left to contemplate,
you know, this tragic
reality of my life."
And I wanted the book
to have that same kind
of manic quality or
hysterical quality.
And that was why I did it.
The fiction I'm working on now
doesn't include any kind of images.
As we move forward and books
are going to be read on screens,
which seems inevitable, for better
or for worse, it would be hard
for literature to resist the
temptation to become more visual.
You know, the newspapers
have, you could say,
fallen prey to that temptation.
If you look at the New York Times
Online, there's embedded video,
there's embedded sound, and
we expect that of a newspaper.
The question is, will readers
expect the same thing of novels
when they're on that vehicle.
It's like, you know, if you
were -- it's imagine being --
pushing a wheelbarrow
on the Autobahn
and all the cars beeping
behind you, saying, like,
speed up or get off the road.
I think that writers are going
to feel those honking horns behind
them, and the challenge will be
to remember what's good about
books, which is that they're slow
and that they're inefficient and
that they're a single task endeavor
and that they're inefficient
and they're not going anywhere.
You know, so much of life,
there's this increased
emphasis on efficiency.
Can we do three things
instead of two at a time?
Can I make it somewhat quicker?
Can my food come to me quicker?
Can I get my job done more quickly?
Can I spend less time
with my family?
You know, this is where we are.
And books are the antidote
to that, but it's going
to be increasingly
difficult to stand
against all of this efficiency.
So readers will have a part to play,
writers will have a part to play,
publishers will have a part to play.
And, you know, another reason
I'm grateful to be here today is
because festivals like this are one
of the great, like, the saving grace
of literature, you know, reminding
us that we're a huge community,
that we're a diverse community, and
that this is at least a good a way
to spend time as updating
your Facebook page.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>> Excuse me.
Can I --
>> Jonathan Safran Foer: Hi.
>> Hi.
>> Jonathan Safran Foer: I'm like
a stroke victim or something.
[ Laughter ]
>> I'm a middle school teacher,
and in April I did Eating Animals
as a discussion group with eighth
graders, and it was fantastic.
They got the book, they
loved the book, it --
my discussion group could
have gone on all afternoon.
But in the 30 days between
when I announced the title
and the actual discussion, I was
paranoid that some parent was going
to call and say, "You've
read the book, right?
You know that there's stuff
in here that's not
appropriate for a 13-year-old."
And I wasn't sure if
I could argue that.
There definitely are maybe
words or, you know --
and I'm wondering if you're
considering going the Pollen route
or Schlosser route and making a
young readers' version of this book?
>> Jonathan Safran Foer: I
haven't given it a lot of thought.
I'm glad that your eighth
graders were so invigorated by it,
and I'm actually not surprised
because high school students
and college students engage
with this subject very
differently than older people do.
Eighteen percent of American
college students describe themselves
as vegetarian.
There are more vegetarians
on American college campuses
than there are Catholics,
and I'm not --
[ Laughter ]
I'm not talking about in
Berkeley or in New York City --
in the entire United States.
This is something that
everybody cares about.
You know, free-range and cage-free
eggs are the fastest growing sector
of the food industry in America --
not in Washington,
D.C., in all of America.
And it's a food that doesn't taste
better and isn't better for you,
but people are buying in droves
because of these values
that we all share.
I mean, I was in a wonderful
position writing this book
because I never felt like I had
to persuade anyone of anything.
I never felt like I had to
change anyone's mind or values,
only present information that is --
I mean, people sometimes cast this
as a moral argument, if --
if what we mean by morality is that
we shouldn't put pregnant animals
in cages so small they
can't turn around,
then we've really lowered
the bar for morality.
So --
[ Applause ]
-- so I take every
opportunity I can to talk
to high school and college students.
And I would say if there are
parents who are concerned about some
of the material in the book, I don't
blame them and you should just take
that material out and share
the rest of the book with them.
There are parts that are very
difficult to read, either because --
not because of my imagination
but because of the imagination
of the factory farm industry.
It's why I wrote this book as
nonfiction rather than a novel
because I wanted everyone
to know whose imagination
was -- was at play.
>> Hi, thank you, for being here.
I guess it feels so overwhelming
sometimes, like, food in general
in this country, we have Senate
bill maybe next week that Cargill
and ConAgra support that's
about food safety, and, like,
I see those companies as the
root of the problem kind of.
And that's the best
legislation we have on the table.
I was wondering since you're in D.C.
and the Capitol's right behind us,
if you've given any thought to the
government's role in the problem --
well, obviously the problem,
but also the solution,
or whether you think it's
just an individual kind
of choices that will rise up?
>> Jonathan Safran Foer: Well,
we don't need the choice.
I mean, there's a lot of emphasis
in our country put on choice
as if it's always a good thing,
as if it put us in closer touch
with our constitution or something.
We don't need the choice.
We don't demand the choice to
have children's toys painted
with lead paint; we
expect our government
to protect us from that choice.
And we don't need the choice to
have Chilean sea bass available.
We don't need the choice to have
salmonella-infected chicken.
You know, there is a three-quarters
of a billion egg recall recently
that most people are probably
aware of, and that's scary.
Eight percent of all
the chicken in all
of our supermarkets is
infected with salmonella.
Between 40 and 70 is
infected with E. Coli.
We're told to cook food at
extremely high temperatures
until there's absolutely no doubt
that anything that was wicked
in it has been cooked through.
We're told to scrub down
our counters with soap,
some people even say with bleach,
to wash our hands vigorously.
We should not be in this position.
Our parents and grandparents
weren't in this position.
The government should be
protecting our food safety.
We shouldn't have available
food that requires us to cook it
at incredibly high temperatures and
wash down all surfaces afterwards.
[ Applause ]
So unfortunately the
U.S.D.A. wears two hats.
One is to endorse American farming
and support American industry,
and the other is to
protect consumers.
In a country in which 99 percent of
our food comes from factory farms,
where health risks are built
into the business model,
environmental destruction's
built into the business model,
they're incompatible positions,
so we need something else,
we need someone who's protecting us.
And maybe it was nice to think
that when the new government came
into office, new things
would happen,
but nothing new has happened.
>> Hi, Jonathan.
I'm a fellow vegan, so thanks --
thank you for all you're
doing for animals.
I appreciate it.
And I was wondering how
much backlash you've gotten
from the meat industry
from this book?
>> Jonathan Safran
Foer: Well, in a way,
this is the most interesting fact
about the publication of the book.
She asked how much backlash there
has been from the meat industry.
Not only has there been no backlash,
there's been no response at all.
So my book has 80 pages of endnotes.
Each page has, I don't
know, 20 endnotes.
So we're talking about a
lot of facts in the book.
Not a single fact has
been called into question.
And it's not the case that the
book just disappeared, you know,
it was like a best seller, I
got to talk about it on TV.
It's not that they just
were willing for it
to be ignored and it was ignored.
It did -- it did enter
the consciousness,
if only in a limited way,
for some amount of time.
But, you know, if I
wrote a book about you,
and I said -- what's your name?
>> Heather.
>> Jonathan Safran Foer: Heather.
If I said, "Heather is a bad person.
We should all spend
less time with Heather.
Heather is destructive
in these ways.
She's cruel in these ways.
We should withdraw our
friendship and support of Heather,"
you would say, "Hey, wait a
minute, that's not right, you know,
you're not telling the whole story.
Some of what you said
is simply untrue.
Some of what you said could
be looked at in another way.
Let me make the argument
for Heather."
No one has stood up and made the
argument for factory farming.
I'm not talking about eating meat,
I'm talking about factory farming.
Every reading I go to, I say,
if somebody wants to stand up
and make the defense of factory
farming, I would love to hear it now
because I looked for three and a
half years and I couldn't find it,
even among factory farmers, and
I did speak to a number of them.
I'm not talking about a
defense that it tastes good
or that it can sometimes seem
cheap, but a really cogent defense
that would stand the test
of a reasonable conversation,
and I haven't found it.
And it's actually disappointed me
that there has been no backlash
because I would love to engage
them in this conversation.
The reason there's been no backlash
is the most telling fact of all
in a book that's filled with facts,
which is the meat industry knows
that if the conversation is
expanded, if people think
about this, they're going to
be discouraged from eating it.
It is not the case that knowledge
leads you to want to eat more of it.
You know, anyone who
follows the newspaper, right,
knows that there has not been
an article in New York Times
or Washington Post
in the last three years
that says this industry is less
environmentally destructive
than we thought; there's
not been an article
that says it is treating animals
less badly than we've thought;
and there's not been an article
that says this food is
safer than we thought.
All news, all information, all
conversation, all thought points
in the same direction, which is
this is more destructive, unhealthy,
and cruel than we had thought.
And so if I were them, I would
be taking exactly the same tact,
which is, let's just hope people
are so ignorant or so willing
to forget what they know that
they'll put aside the values
that they have in the
interest of what?
Not in the interest of
the Thanksgiving turkey,
that's not what we're talking
about, or the Christmas ham.
We're talking about a McDonald's
hamburger, Chicken McNuggets.
That's what's at stake.
That's what is responsible for
this industry that we have.
And that's what we have to
withdraw our support from.
It think --
[ Applause ]
-- it's time for one more questions.
Sorry to the others.
>> Hi. I'm sorry to go a bit off
subject, but I just want to talk
about Everything's Illuminated
because I think that's one
of the best pieces of literature
that I've read in quite some time,
and I was personally moved by it.
And I have a question.
What made you personally want
to actually write about it,
and what do you think that we
can learn from such a story
as that as you've written?
>> Jonathan Safran Foer:
So she asked two questions:
What made me want to write
Everything is Illuminated?
And what do I think
we can learn from it?
I don't think we can
learn anything from it.
I don't think novels are written
to be learned from in that way.
I think the kind of
education that happens
in a novel is very unpredictable
and very subtle and has to do not
with what kind of politics
we should have,
but who we might be more
similar to than we'd thought.
You know, my first experience
as a published author was I did a
radio show and it was call-in show,
and someone -- someone -- the
first caller, in fact, said,
"I want to thank you
for writing this book
because you told my family story.
And I'd never seen it or
heard it in that way."
And so in my mind, I'm imagining
the caller on the other end,
and I thought, oh, it's a
20-something Jewish guy,
glasses, brown hair, [inaudible].
And he said, "As a 65-year-old
black man living in Trenton,"
[ Laughter ]
and my reaction is basically
like yours, I kind of chuckled
and I was surprised, and I've
thought a lot about that since then,
and shame on me for being surprised,
and shame on us for laughing
because it suggests that the
things we feel most deeply
or our family stories
are somehow told
through the circumstances
of our lives.
Like the fact that I was 25 and
he was 65 should matter in terms
of what we felt most deeply or what
our family stories boil down to,
or that he was a black person
and I was white person,
or that I was Jewish and he was not.
You know, literature is
the antidote to that idea,
the idea that we are
closer to people
or we will better understand
people who lives --
who live lives that are ours.
And there aren't very many antidotes
in the world left to that which is
such -- makes it such a shame
that the arts aren't a bigger part
of how we relate to the people that
most desperately need to relate to.
You know, if you think about our
military presence in the Middle East
or our militaristic
presence, we have --
how many people in this room have
read a work in Arabic in translation
in the last year or five
years, I mean, very few.
And if that is the way that we
communicate our humanity best --
and I do believe it is -- then
we're in deep trouble if that kind
of conversation isn't taking place.
So --
[ Applause ]
I'm getting the overtime card.
So I'll be signing books
in some tent over there.
Thank you very much for coming.
[ Applause ]